bonsoir à tout bonsoir à tous bienvenue
sur le tapis rouge du festival de cannes
pour cette deuxième soirée de la 74e
édition
une soirée où j'ai envie de dire tout
s'est bien passé puisque le film ce soir
c'est tout s'est bien passé de françois
ozon où on retrouve sophie marceau andré
dussollier géraldine pailhas et gta sur
les marches il y avait aussi beaucoup
beaucoup de monde avec nous regardez
à 9h15 pistes audio
je suis si heureuse d'être là ça fait du
bien ça fait vraiment du bien ces deux
ans en cinéma s'en fait sens comme ça
dans la france moi j'étais à se
débloquer les états unis donc je suis
très ému d'être à ce soir
alors il ya quelques années c'était le
prix d'interprétation le pour le fils de
fatih akin qu'est ce que ça change dans
la ville a dit l'actrice d'avoir un prix
d'interprétation à cannes
bah je sais pas si cela change quelque
chose mais j'ai l'impression d'avoir
participé à un film qui a marqué des
gens qu et on a ri connu ça dans l'islam
aux marrons des hyper fier et c'est sûr
que ça peut-être changer un regard de
certains scénaristes sur moi et
réalisateur donc des compositions sont
venus soi même plus souvent et plus
intéressant peut-être mais les
prochaines en se retrouvant montée des
marches agenda
vera
[Musique]
ce soir vous avez bien tout se passe
très très bien
alors est ce que vous vous amusez à 4 je
suis ravie ici à 15 pouvoir me déplacer
de partager des films et des côtes de
bourg a fait une période difficile pour
nous tous
[Musique]
enfin isabelle va bien mais super un
petit mot sur cette année c'est un peu
spécial parce que vous vous venez du
festival d'avignon vous avez ouvert ont
mené au festival de même si colette
différence en fait la différence
il n'y a pas de red carpet à avignon se
sont réunis comme le nouveau film de
françois ozon avec plaisir et ce qui
représente pour vous françois il
représente le metteur en scène de l'ifa
mais un très grand metteur en scène très
versatile qui peut ce qu'il sait c'est
dans tous les genres merci beaucoup
isabelle merci et les films ce matin
j'étais comme ça est très courageuse il
est très courageux pour
moi je vous rendrai c'est le trajet pour
françois quel niveau courage à vous a
demandé cette invitation la pape a
demandé de courage mais en tout cas j'ai
dû surmonter les émotions dès le départ
et après c'est que de la joie et
l'excitation avec français on s'amuse
beaucoup même
maintenant les films graves il sait
comment d'avoir sophie marceau comme ça
c'est super mais aussi via les mêmes
questions je pense qu'elle me répondre à
la même façon et moi je fais tout moi
j'ai une soeur elle en a pas et on s'est
choisi sans vouloir être trop cucul
on est assez gare sommes toutes les deux
en fait et ça a été une vraiment très
très chouette rencontre juste un petit
mot lie à la présentation du qui faisait
dans quelques instants
prenez comment la un peu angoissé en
même temps heureux d'être là ouais parce
que
voilà on est content plus festival sauf
vers on est content de présenter le film
l'année dernière mon film était 85 été
sectionnés festival a pas eu lieu
et là je suis très heureux d'être là
avec le avec ce film j'ai une pensée
particulière à imad hamad ben bernanke
qui a écrit ce livre et dont j'ai fait
l'adaptation mairie c'est quelque chose
de très fort c'est que quand j'ai vu le
film dans ma tête j'avais la même voie
que celle que j'avais quand j'étais
libre comment on arrive à ça
je sais pas je crois que j'ai eu besoin
de temps pour m'approprier se livrer la
mort des manuels peut-être m'a aidé à
mieux comprendre ce qu'elle avait
traversé ce qu'elle avait vécu ces
histoires fortes c'est une histoire
d'actualité aussi c'est important de
raconter de montrer cette histoire
aujourd'hui c'est pas un film à ce sujet
pour moi c'est d'abord un film sur une
famille et sur des relations père fille
c'est ça surtout qui m'a plu et après il
ya un fond
qui est un sujet de société mais ce qui
m'a intéressé c'est regarder qui nous
rejoint là ce qui m'intéressait c'était
sophie voilà ce qu'il incarne le
personnage de même aller c'est plus
qu'une incarnation c'est vraiment ce que
je te disais à françois c'est quand je
j'y voyais film jim gens que j'avais la
même boîte branchée des livres dans ma
tête
comment vous êtes arrivé à sa a comme
vous j'avais le livre dans la tête qui
était écrit pour un film qui a été écrit
pour françois je pense ça correspond
film qu'il aime enfin il en a fait
beaucoup étaient très différents mais je
crois qu'il était très touché par cette
femme par le caractère de cette femme et
sa vie autour de ce père qui est un
personnage très charismatique très
insupportable est magnifique très libre
et voilà et on parle de choses qui sont
les choses de la vie les choses des
liens familiaux à travers des événements
qui nous arrive et qui sont difficiles
voilà si on appeler papa aussi
voilà toute la famille merci françois
alors c'est une question pour tous les
deux parce que à plein de niveaux si
c'est extrêmement courageuse que vous
faites dans ce film là parce que
évidemment ça touche tout le monde cette
histoire on est tous qu'on a tous vécu
ça on est tous concerné par cette
histoire là donc oui commençons par ou
andré c
moi je vous a fallu pour jouer ce
rôle-là toujours excitant d'avoir un
rôle où il ya beaucoup de choses à créa
va faire évidemment c'était
fort impressionnant de jouer à un homme
tout d'un coup qu'un avc et qui à la
détermination de son année de mettre un
terme à sa vie et qui va demander à sa
fille de l'aider les bons il ya des
défis que c'est excitant
voilà andré a pris beaucoup de plaisir à
être méchant parfois être sarcastique
envoyer chier les normes et les codes et
c'est un plaisir aussi pour l'acteur de
voir le tracteur jouer donner de
l'émotion ans un film qui est sur
l'émotion mais qui aussi sur les
surprises de la vie
voilà si pas toujours on peut se marrer
aussi quoi et je pense français ou en
couleur quand même sur son personnage il
est il a pris énormément de plaisir à
jouer quand c'était rien que ça c'était
un bonheur de le voir libre entre le
drame et puis la comédie des choses
drôles c'est bon on n'est pas allé dans
le pathos sans fin c'est françois ozon
qui a voulu raconter la vie telle
qu'elle est avec tous les moments
indifférent que va subir tous les
protagonistes de l'histoire c'était se
déporte j'ai laissé monter les marches
merci infiniment merci beaucoup et bravo
pour le film belle soirée sur les
marches du 64e festival de cannes et
demain ça ne devrait être pas mal
puisqu'on aura matt damon avec nous
rendez vous sur canal+
à demain